if you're like me you've probably
noticed that over the last number of
years the phrase live-action remake has
become something of a hot-button issue
and to some extent I can understand why
there's both love and hate for the
recreation of these beloved childhood
stories but upfront I want to make
something clear when I say live-action
isn't an upgrade I'm not suggesting that
animation is inherently superior to
live-action in fact it's quite the
opposite what I mean is that one isn't
inherently better than the other each
medium offers something the other can't
adding value to what are known as the
four cornerstones of storytelling in
their own unique ways these four
cornerstones are known as plot setting
theme and character and within each
individual story ever told
these are prioritized differently for
instance attack and Titan has a strong
focus on plot and setting and while
character isn't ignored it receives less
focus than the plot consistency and
world-building within the comic
understanding this is important because
depending on the genre or nature of a
story being told the visual
representation of the events on screen
can either serve to enhance or in some
cases take away from the final product
if the wrong property is adapted in
other words 2d animation CGI and
live-action offer different strengths
and weaknesses to a story which means
you need to be extremely careful when
deciding what animated property receives
a live-action adaptation or vice-versa
however lately as many of you might have
noticed for better or worse we are deep
in the throes of a Disney remake
renascence indiscriminately the mouse
seems to be throwing live-action remakes
of beloved franchises left right and
center seemingly without regard for
whether or not it translates well into
the format at all with 2019 already
having received three with two more on
the way before the year ends but why do
people have a problem with this well it
seems to be the case that classic films
are being chosen not because they'd
benefit from the live-action format but
because they're popular as I said
different stories ask for different
things from its visuals and if the story
that's being told is focusing on aspects
that are not enhanced by the visuals you
get something like this now this is not
to suggest that live-action remakes or
reimagining x' are a bad idea in fact I
think with the right properties they are
a great idea and have a chance at being
superior to the originals if chosen for
the right reasons and done correctly as
I said the four major components for any
story
our unique combination of plot setting
theme and character if an animated
feature deals with a gritty realistic
world of human characters it stands to
reason a live-action adaptation could
add to these areas of the film in ways
animation could not however there is a
massive problem a stigma that animation
hasn't been able to shake in decades at
this moment in time the mainstream
belief is that live-action is an
objective improvement higher-quality and
for all ages all the while the unique
advantages animation provides us with
our being ignored or forgotten simply
cast aside as something for children
let's talk about the Lion King the
staggering level of detail and
perfection that these photorealistic
animals March chat and sing across the
screen with is nothing short of
incredible so much so you'd be forgiven
for forgetting that these are actually
CGI models generated on a computer it's
abundantly clear that an absurd amount
of time effort and skill went into
making this animated world as true to
the real world
as possible which makes what I'm about
to say all the more difficult the
visuals don't communicate effectively
and I think the creator of Toy Story
said it best one of my mentors whose
work really really always inspired me
was Chuck Jones who was a great Warner
Brothers cartoon director he always said
John great animation you should turn the
sound off and still be able to tell
what's going on you can pick any scene
at random from the original Lion King
film and without context you can
understand what the characters are
feeling and even what their motivations
are for instance if you take images from
this scene in the original film and try
to decipher what the emotions and
motivations behind the characters were
you'd find it's remarkably easy this
isn't by accident the purpose of the
visuals behind any story is to enhance
the communication of the narrative
because of this it's possible to watch
the original Lion King without sound and
still understand what's going on however
if that same approach was taken with the
live-action film you'll find that you
receive a tiny fraction of the
information in comparison in saying that
I realize it might prompt some of you to
say what doesn't matter if they're
communicating visually they're talking I
get the information that way in saying
this you have made an argument for radio
if the
don't matter why not whip some vaguely
similar footage from a bunch of wildlife
documentaries and call it a day I'll
tell you why because more information is
communicated through visuals than
through dialogue and the best example of
that is this where the staggering up a
hill the inclusion of a knowing smile
and the gentle glide of a balloon
towards a hospital bed can take you
through a whirlwind of emotions unlike
anything dialog can grant you in that
time if you don't understand what visual
storytelling is I implore you to watch
Disney Pixar's on within the first 15
minutes you will have an intimate
understanding of what it is and why it's
important now don't get me wrong
live-action films can and have famously
told their stories without words but as
we continue to push the limits of CGI
into the realm of photo realism we're
starting to lose sight of what the
visuals of a film are actually therefore
to communicate emotion to communicate
motive to tell a story and I think no
other live-action remake better embodies
that mistake than The Lion King in order
to overcompensate for its lack of
expression the character models in the
Lion King are forced to express
themselves through body language funnily
enough for the exact same reasons the
Power Rangers overact when they're in
the ranger suits because their faces
cannot be seen
additionally in scenes that would
utilize an abundance of color to
emphasize the fantastical imagination
and naivety of a character's youth this
photorealistic aesthetic is forced to
downplay these moments in an effort to
make it more uniform with the rest of
the production the result is something
much less visually striking and
interesting and doesn't serve the
character and setting as effectively as
the animated Lion King did the more I
analyze this film's use of CGI for
realism the more it makes me realize
that it's less an effective storytelling
device and more so an impressive tech
demonstration something that will have
people say man that looks gorgeous and
it is gorgeous and impressive and all
the other things people have been saying
online about it but it's not a good
storytelling device exhausting
everything it has to offer in the first
acts admittedly gorgeous opening
sequence however there is one place
where traditional 2d animation is still
King and unlike anywhere else is not
stigmatized as simply children's
entertainment
Japan unlike the United States in
Hollywood the Japanese anime industry
has wall-to-wall variation in its
animated products and at this point I
think it's safe to say that there's
nothing they won't animate unlike the
West where they relegate anime to its
own genre in the East anime covers
anything and everything from choose
entertainment to tragic war stories to
epic romances panning lifetimes and
action adventure thriller Ides anime as
a concept and product is a multi-billion
dollar industry providing thousands of
people with work in Japan and
entertainment across the world because
nowhere else will you see an animated
love story of this quality in 2019 that
is meant for adults nowhere else will
you get animated horror films and TV
shows this is a quarter of the market
that the West is ignoring and for better
or worse
Japan is capitalizing on in the most
effective of ways this however does not
mean that they are free from the bad
live-action remake plagued not by a long
shot
I think at this point is important to
reiterate that there can be bad animated
TV shows and movies the same way there
can be bad live-action TV shows and
movies it all boils down to the artistic
integrity of the product if something is
made exclusively because it's a cash
grab the likelihood of there being a
great idea behind it is significantly
lessened and while there have been some
awful live-action adaptations of some of
my favorite series I still don't think
that live-action adaptations are
inherently a bad idea if executed
correctly earlier in the video I
mentioned that there are things
animation can offer a product that no
other medium can the same can be said
for live-action
for instance despite its incredibly
tone-deaf and incomprehensible execution
Netflix either by designer by chance was
onto something when they attempted to
adapt Death Note into a live-action
format the themes setting plot and
characters of Death Note don't
necessarily depend on animation for
their expression and success it's a
series that's driven by plot and themes
which means Death Note if handled
correctly could stand to be made all the
more effective if shown in reality every
death every chase every sudden
realization stands to be made all the
more real and intense
if faithfully adapted into live-action
as long as the themes characters and
settings of a given property doesn't
heavily rely on animation to communicate
its information there exists the
possibility of an effective live-action
remake
JJ Abrams is currently working on a
live-action adaptation of the Japanese
smash hit your name right now and if
handled correctly it could work
extremely well the horror and emotion of
attack on Titan can make an effective
transition to live action if tackled
correctly also and the list goes on but
that's not to say that all properties
can Dragon Ball has famously been the
victim of bad live-action adaptations
one that entirely missed the point of
the series however even if handled with
better care I'm not convinced that a
live-action adaptation would enhance the
product overall the characters and
personalities of Dragon Ball express
themselves in extreme ways by making use
of its animated format and I'm still not
convinced that live action would create
more visually interesting fight
sequences in the style of Dragon Ball
essentially I think track of all stands
to lose more by injecting realism into a
story that it stands to gain
our imaginations know no limits new
innovative ways of telling stories are
being created all the time
and in this fast-paced world where we
are amazed and looking forward to the
opportunities and possibilities the
future holds I think it's important to
not cast aside what once was animation
offers possibilities no other medium can
it can bring you into the mind of a
young kid the spirit of a warrior and
the body of your favorite creature but
as years pass by it seems to be fading
into the background more and more and so
as future technologies are being
invented and upgraded by the day it's
important to not mistake the past as
inferior only in understanding and
appreciating that every medium offers
something unique to its design will film
studios be equipped to make the educated
decisions necessary to deliver the
stories that capture our imaginations
only then will these questionable
decisions become a thing of the past and
only then will our friends families and
children continue to be transported to
infinity and beyond thanks for watching
[Music]